[Musique]
le vieux lille plongé dans la pénombre
pendant quelques heures plus d'éclairage
public dans une soixantaine de postes
d'alimentation les fusibles ont disparu
une action coup de poing d'agents edf
qui n'a guère perturbé les passants le
centre de l'île dans l'obscurité
tout comme celui de roubaix et de
tourcoing où la même les feux tricolores
ne fonctionnaient plus des grévistes qui
éteignent la lumière sans complexe pour
exposer au grand jour leurs
revendications ou nous tous les moyens
sont bons pour des salariés de se faire
entendre je pense que couper l'éclairage
public c'était une façon saine et
sereine de faire savoir au niveau
national ce qui est en train de se
passer à rouen aussi le courant a sauté
une heure sans électricité pour 70 mille
abonnés et cette fois ci des bâtiments
publics ont été touchées dont l'hôpital
où les groupes électrogènes ont dû en
urgence prendre le relais
[Musique]